all right you're done let's take a look
at the solution while we cannot insert a
vector directly you can easily convert a
vector to an array once we've done this
the bulk insert method will insert very
efficiently as you can see we've
uncommented out these next series of
lines this allows us to test our output
to make sure that we've actually
inserted the right thing into the
database let's actually run our app and
as you can see we're actually reading
the data out of the database that we
just inserted all correctly now our
back-end will update efficiently but we
really need a way to update the
front-end without doing it on the main
UI thread
now our back-end will update efficiently
but we really need to be querying things
before requesting them from the internet
after all the important is to have a
responsive application we're still not
even updating the screen until after
we've pulled data down from the web we
also want to avoid doing our query on
the UI thread
because doing operations like queries on
the UI thread cause Android to not be
able to draw frames fast enough which
introduces framerate jitter
fortunately Android offers a pattern for
that known as loaders